[موسيقى]
بالنسبه لنا الاتفاقيات مع اسرائيل
المفروض انها لا زالت قائمه ونحن لا يمكن
ان
نتراجع او نتخلى عن اتفاقيه الا انهم
بتصرفاتهم منذ فتره من الزمن منذ اكثر من
ست سبع سنوات
وهم ينقذون كل ما تم الاتفاق عليه
وبالتالي يعني يعملون عكس كل هذه
الاتفاقيات امام هذا الوضع لا نملك ان
نبقى على التمسك والالتزام بهذه
الاتفاقيات ولذلك نحن في اي لحظه ممكن ان
نخلي طرفنا منها
[موسيقى]
لا لا طبعا انا مش متفائل لسبب
اللي ضربنا على مدى 70 سنه 74 سنه مش راح
ينصفنا هذه الايام الشيء الاخر وبصراحه
الذي يقف حجر عثره في طريق تنفيذ القرارات
وبالذات قرارات
لاسرائيل في
رفضها لكلها لعدم الالتزام بهذه القرارات
يعني طالب امريكا
تجلس مع الامريكان نتحدث بهذه القضايا لعل
وعسى ياتي وقت
يتغير الموقف الامريكي يتغير اخوك ان شاء
الله عند ذلك نحن
[موسيقى]